hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today are going to be
going over an aggressive opening called
the scotch game it and it derives from
the scotch game which is pawnee for
pawnee v 9 f3 knight c6 pawn to d4 and
then after pawn takes here on d4 instead
of recapturing with the night here on d4
the bishop is going to come to c4 for
going this material right away giving up
that pawn on d4 for a large lead in
development also as you can tell this
light squared bishop is attacking this
square on f7 so white's really saying
that hey i have a strong attack here so
i don't mind giving up this pawn here on
d4 now there's four main variations that
you will see from black as far as the
defense and so we're going to be kind of
going over the main lines that you will
see the first one that you'll see is
bishop here to c5 kind of the italian
game another one you may see is the
bishop coming down to b4 again checking
the white King here in a1 you also may
say the bishop come here to e7 getting
ready to castle on the King side and the
last one that you may see is Knight to
f6 going into kind of the two Knights
defense here from black and just kind of
going from there so those are the four
variations and we'll kind of go into it
and kind of give you some some things to
look out for in the opening and some
very aggressive lines you can try out on
your opponent's during the Scotch gambit
the first variation that we're going to
be going over today is Bishop to c5 kind
of transitioning into the Italian game
with both the bishops here on the C file
white predominantly has three main lines
from here I'm going to kind of go over
briefly all of them and then
specifically spend a little bit more
time on the opening that I actually find
most success with but the first opening
that you would see it's a very
aggressive line it's Knight to g5
putting a lot of pressure on this pawn
on f7 black needs to respawn with Knight
to h6 again he needs defenders on this
Square on f7 because White's just
putting a lot a lot of pressure on that
from here y can continue with Queen to a
tribe again building up that that
pressure here on f7 black has to be
careful if he tries to do anything funny
white can definitely run over him
but definitely feel free to try this one
out I do think it's a little bit easier
for black to equalize in this so I don't
play this as much but a lot of people do
find success with this so I definitely
want to make sure you guys were aware of
it another thing that you can do I don't
think it's as aggressive as I like to
play but a lot of players from here just
like to go ahead and castle on the
kingside and the third option which I'm
going to advocate because I find a lot
of success with it is just pawn here to
c3 and this does a lot of things but it
really pressures this center of the
board right here and from here a lot of
times you'll just see black take with
this pawn here on c3 the great thing
about this as soon as black captures
here on c3 Y can go ahead and take here
on f7 checking the King here on e8 now
black has many different options his
worst option would just be to bring you
know his King to let's say f8 he's going
to be behind a material y can go ahead
and capture here on c3 if he wants to
with his knight great development from
here from white black is pretty much
going to have his king running around
the board he can't castle on either side
of the board if he decides to go ahead
and capture which is probably the best
move but again he's going to be running
around the board with his king for the
rest of the game anyway but after he
captures here on f7
then the Queen can immediately come here
to d5 obviously he's not only attacking
this King here on f7 but he's also
attacking this bishop here on c5 black
does have a few options here if he does
fall from one of the traps he could
always come to f6 which is a terrible
move you're then going to have checkmate
in a few moves the bishop can come here
to g5 check after the King comes over
then you sweet swing your Queen over to
f5 and there's only one move for the
King comes over here to h5 and then with
g4 that is checkmate so that's one
option hopefully he does he's not that
terrible but you know he could be he
could also bring it over to g6 again you
really want to bring it back to the
eighth rank if possible from here it's
just going to be checkmate in one with
you no Queen over to f5 if he goes
anywhere else if he just brings it let's
say back to e8 and that's fine Queens is
going to come over here and capture here
on
see five again the king can no longer
move he's going to be in the center of
the board being chased around the rest
of the game this is going to be very
very good for white going for it so just
you know that simple little move
bringing your pawn up here to c3 all of
a sudden things just fall apart for
black now he doesn't necessarily have to
take if we come back here after this
move pawn to c3 another move you may see
is Knight to f6 very very common again
this is the two Knights defense
sometimes you'll see it even before the
Bishop comes out here to c5 any times
you see this you're just going to go
ahead and move your pawn forward again
trying to kick this knight off the board
trying to see where he wants to go now
really beginner players will just kick
their knight back to g8 they're just
losing more and more momentum or tempo
as a lot of people call it but they
can't they do have two other moves they
can always bring their pawn down to d5
and from here the bishops just going to
come over to b5 putting a lot of
pressure right here on this Knight
pinning it down to the King or another
move you may see is the knight coming
down here to e4 and then the bishop can
just swing here to d5 attacking both
this night here on c6 or the night here
on e4 again a very very good move from
white it's going to have a very very
strong game again later on into the game
the Queen can come here to b3 if it
needs to supporting this Bishop here on
d5 y can always castle on the Kings side
if the white you know if White's ever
captured here on c3 then white can
always you know recapture with this
night here on c3 again this is a great
square for this Knight again a lot of
different options for white and black
really has to be very very careful
because again anytime white wants to he
can come over here and capture this pawn
here on f7 if let's say this pawn comes
down and captures on c3 so that's
definitely why out of all the different
options that I really like just the
simple move of playing pawn c2 to c3
next variation we're going to be looking
at is Bishop down to b4 and if you've
never played from blacks perspective
before this seems like a logical move
come down develop one of your pieces
attack your opponent's King you do
some pressure on this III square so he
may think that you know the pawns not
gonna come up here to c3 but it is so
the pawns just going to come here to c3
if black recaptures right here why it's
going to recapture with his pawn forcing
this bishop to move back now black does
have a lot of different places he can go
if he does come to c5 hopefully you've
seen you know this position on the board
before and you know right away that
White's going to come over here and
capture here on f7 so that after the
King comes backing recaptures then the
Queen's going to come back and take this
bishop right here again this black King
is going to be chased all over the board
it's not going to have nowhere safe to
go because he cannot castle for the rest
of the game so again that the black
bishop doesn't have to go to c5 he could
always come back to you know a5 where
from here since the King is being pinned
down this pawn with his Bishop then
white can go ahead and castle on the
King side he can always if he wanted to
bring the knight up here to g5 again
putting a lot of pressure on this square
on f7 the bishop if let's say the bishop
comes back to d6 this is pretty good
mostly because he's blocking off you
know this pawn here on d7 which is a
strong pawn to go ahead and start to
push forward so he can give his lights
for a [ __ ] involved into the game
blacks kind of choking himself right now
there's not a lot of room for him to
develop right here from here y can kind
of do the same thing go and castle on
the King side but in this case he can
you know start to bring his rook over to
e 1 once his rooks on e1 he can start to
push forward with his pawns you know
again doing a lot of pressure on black
he could always bring his Queen over to
b3 again lining up his Queen and his
LightSquared Bishop on this f7 square
right here so white has a lot of
different options kind of the board is
open for him he can always get his dark
square Bishop involved into the game
later on if he wants to black again
still trying to figure out what he's
going to do right now there's there's no
real way for him to develop his pieces
very easily it's going to take him quite
a few moves and white just has so many
different options so definitely another
good option again black could always
bring his bishop
back to if we come back here he could
always bring his bishop back to let's
say f8 we're going to talk about f7 here
shortly but if you bring them back to f8
this is again a terrible move you never
want to develop your pieces allow your
opponent's to start to move forward and
then the one piece that you did move out
bring it back to the eighth row you know
why it's just going to have a huge huge
developmental advantage right here you
know it's going to be really hard for
block to overcome that the next
variation that we're going to be looking
at is Bishop to e7
now from here white really has three
main options two of which are very very
sound but I just don't play that much
and then the third one which I think's
just a little bit more exciting so I've
played a lot but the first ones just
castling on the kingside again this is
this is an okay move again getting ready
to develop your other pieces bring your
rook over to e1 this is completely fun
also just taking here on d4 with your
knight that's completely ok move the
move that I really like is just pawn
here to c3 now if he does take White has
a strong attack he can bring his queen
up to d5 again we've kind of seen this
Queen coming to d5 quite a bit in the
scotch game but so kind of get used to
it again putting a lot of pressure on
this f7 square what black really has to
figure out how to defend this really the
only good way to defend this is bringing
the knight over here to h6 y can go
ahead and recapture that with his bishop
here on h6 and then blacks going to just
castle on the King side obviously it's
not going to do any good if he takes
with his pawn right now because again
White's still threatening this Queen
takes here on f7 so after black captures
here on the King side white has a few
options I think that the best option for
here is white to go ahead and develop
his minor piece right here to c3
capturing this pawn he's okay to go
ahead and give up this Bishop here on h6
so after the the pawn takes then the
Queen's going to swing over here to h5
again putting a ton of pressure both
this Bishop here in this Queen or both
attacking this
on f7 the Queen if he wants to next move
can go ahead and take this pawn on h6
again this there's just a huge gaping
hole right here to attack this King it's
really going to be hard for him to hold
on the rest of the game so you know
again that's why I like that subtle move
that pawn from c2 to c3 even when the
bishop starts here on e7 I think it's a
very very powerful move now again he
doesn't necessarily have to capture so
if we come back here if it's just this
pawn - from c2 to c3 and let's say the
Knights going to come over here to f6
very common move same theme as we've
seen before the pawn just going to kind
of push forward with pawn to e5 the
Knights now going to come here to two
different options so the knight could
come down here - to e4 and now the
bishop is going to come here to d5 again
putting pressure both on this knight on
c6 and on this knight on e4 or another
move you may see a lot is you know
counter attacking you could see that the
pawn come down here to d5 now typically
in in the past variations we've seen
just the bishop coming here to b5 again
you don't want to get rid of your bishop
you don't want to trade that off so you
go ahead and move your bishop here to b5
hitting the knight down but instead
we're going to do something a little bit
different and it's only because the
bishop is here on e7 so instead of
bringing our bishop we're going to go
ahead and take here on f6 and if white
or if black responds taking with this
pawn here on c4 then as you can tell why
we excited it's decided to exchange and
that is because we can now take here on
e7 gobbling up more and more pieces so
this is definitely going to be winning
for white so a lot of different
variations and they all again stem from
this nice little move pawns c2 to c3
which is why I think it's a huge asset
as you're going through all the
different variations again some others
are very very solid as well but I think
against a human component opponent the
c2 to c3 if black has not seen it just
destroys them from all the play testing
that I've seen using the
Scotch gambit the last variation we're
going to be going over is just the two
Knights defense which we'll see quite
often and it's just night here to f6
again as we've talked about before
hopefully you've seen the theme right
here from here why she's going to push
forward with this pawn here to e5 Black
has a few different options probably one
of his strongest one right here again
the two Knights defense is probably one
of the stronger defenses that he can
play there in this but if he does decide
to go ahead and bring his knight down
here to g4 again he does have two
attackers on this pawn right here
White's just going to go ahead and
castle on the kingside he's not too
worried about this he right now only has
this night here on f3 but he kind of has
this rook as well meaning that you know
if the knight were to capture here on e5
you know after the knight captures and
after the knight recaptures here on e5
then the rook can come in here pin down
this Knight to the King black could
always try to you know bring his pawn
here to d6 so if you know white captures
right here but all white really has to
do now is remove that piece and he could
just play pawn to f4 meaning that the
knight can no longer move but he is
pinned down with this rook here to the
King so he's going to end up losing this
piece so again all you have to do if you
see that knight coming over here to d4
just go ahead and castle on the King
side now another another option that you
may see instead of the knight coming
down here to g4 you could always see
just Knight to e4 you don't see it as
much but I've I've seen this every now
and then but all in all I still think
even regardless of where he does play I
think white has a lot of different
options and it's going to play really
really well so those are the four main
lines that you'll really see in the
Scotch gamete so play around with it let
me know what you guys think I've had
great success with it I really enjoy
these really aggressive lines from white
putting a lot of pressure on black early
on into the game always setting mini
traps along the way that anytime they
think they're making a good move you can
just kind of in
we attack and then chase their King
around for the rest of the game I love
that hopefully you guys enjoy that as
well if you haven't seen this opening
before I think you're really going to
enjoy it so check it out and let me know
what you guys think and I'll see you
guys in the next video thanks for
watching